the Koran ha river in the Amazon
rainforest is home to villagers who
cluster along its banks it's also home
to isolated tribes these tribes live
deep in the forest canoes are the best
way to travel in this remote part of
Peru villagers farm and retain some
traditional ways their modest belongings
include pots pans and machetes now these
items are going missing from their huts
villagers are worried but they know the
culprits the isolated forest people
science magazine went to find out why
these tribes are emerging this is Andrew
Lawler from science magazine we're in
Santa Rey which is the last village on
the Karanja River before you get to the
alta Peru
observe we're here with Eva who is a
member of an isolated tribe who has come
out and serves as a kind of go between
the villagers and eepa straddles the
worlds of the village and forest people
wears clothes but still lives a
traditional life he explains that he
often visits his family in the jungle
but the jungle is shrinking pushing out
isolated people in other parts of the
Amazon to
one tribe said they fled from outsiders
who attack them another tribe appeared
near a riverbank asking where the game
had gone outsiders are transforming the
forest they are harvesting trees
smuggling cocaine and mining but worse
they also carry diseases at sicken and
kill isolated people these forest tribes
are among the last people on earth who
live apart from modern life and we are
not prepared to protect them
you